Titans go you know I'm not sure there's
a superhero property that has been as
drastically reimagined in as few
adaptations as the Teen Titans because
when it comes to the non comics versions
of these characters and setting aside
random one-off appearances here and
there there's basically the 2003 Teen
Titan animated series the far sillier
Teen Titans go and its affiliated movie
and now the live-action titans series
which is dark violent and pretty much
devoid of jokes it makes one wonder if
that first animated series was like
subject to some mad science experiment
where its component parts of overwrought
drama and abject goofiness were split
into separate entities like that time
that Bruce Banner and the Hulk became
separate people or the whole red and
blue Superman thing from the late 90s
the 90s well look however we got here
today I'm gonna be taking a look at that
dark live-action version that premiered
last year so prior to being commissioned
by a patreon supporter to cover this I
really had not followed much about it
since the somewhat infamous first
trailer which fit which featured Dick
Grayson aka Robin delivering this
immortal gem
and that pretty much killed any interest
I might have had deadness tracks that
trailer as a whole of that line in
particular painted the whole thing is
just this edge Lord nonsense that
falsely equated dark with mature now I
don't have a problem with dark material
but I'm frequently frustrated by it
because I feel like so many creators
think that the dark and edgy version of
something is somehow self justified but
the best dark stories especially dark
superhero stories they have a depth that
makes the darkness go down well where it
becomes painful is when a story just
wallows in being dark and gritty but
doesn't appear to be using that
aesthetic to any narrative end there
isn't a reason to do it and I really
dreaded that being the case for titans
so imagine my surprise when the show
turned out to actually be pretty good
not perfect there are problems I'll get
to them but the problems it has aren't
the ones I was expecting it's not dark
just for its own sake it's dark because
that's the element of young adulthood
that it's actively playing to because I
think back on it most of us go through
an angsty nobody understands me phase in
our lives and there's a reason that for
most of us this starts in adolescence
because that's the point where we
realize that the world is harsher than
when we're told when we were younger but
we also don't have the power or
authority to do anything about it we
feel trapped by a world that couldn't
care less about us we self-doubt we
question we get introspective in a way
that tends to lower our self-esteem and
our confidence and that is the aspect of
adolescent
that this show was handling which makes
the darker approach actually fit the
story instead of feeling like a forced
attempt at superficial maturity so if
you're not familiar with the Teen Titans
the team first appeared in the 1960s
with the premise of basically putting
the teen sidekicks together from some of
their own adventures you know various
sidekicks to various adult superheroes
now the original team lineup that
continued on through the 70s but it
isn't really worth dwelling on that too
much because it was the second iteration
that served as the template for the
characters that most folks now know as
the Teen Titans so in 1980 readers were
introduced to the New Teen Titans which
carried over several original members
including Robin but more importantly
brought to the character of Beast Boy
over from the Doom Patrol and introduced
the new characters of cyborg Raven and
Starfire and it's these five that have
become the iconic lineup of the team
they're the ones in both cartoon
versions the characters generally
expected to appear when the name Teen
Titan shows up
now this live-action Titans it doesn't
feature cyborg although oddly enough he
debuted in the Doom Patrol show that
launched last month I don't know it's
weird but as a result yeah we have a
core group of four who are primarily
addressed by normal names so we have
dick aka Robin
Rachel aka Raven Garfield usually
shortened to gar aka Beast Boy and Cory
aka Starfire the narrative is primarily
driven by the character of Rachel which
was a good call for a number of reasons
while all the characters have their own
things going on hers is the storyline
with the biggest consequences and it
means the heroes can't just hunker down
and avoid what's going on rachel has
some pretty dark power
that frightened her and terrify the
woman she believes to be her mother
the angle that the show goes for is a
borderline multiple personality thing
with the Raven appearing to be something
that kind of takes Rachael over as
opposed to you know anything that she
has much control over now
that angle on it could have ended up
being pretty cheesy but the show does a
very smart thing by making the voice of
Raven bear more than a passing
resemblance to the negative hateful and
self-critical voice that many of us have
in our teenage years and sometimes well
beyond them the way in which rachel is
berated and sneered at resembles nothing
so much as a manifestation of depression
that voice that will always remind you
how worthless you are no matter what
else is going on around you
so again it's not edgy for its own sake
it fits the themes of the show that it's
working with Rachel's already turbulent
world gets turned on its head when the
woman she thought was her mother is
killed directly in front of her and she
finds herself being tracked down by a
sort of brainwashing cult that claims
allegiance to her father
fans of the character already know where
that's going but the show doesn't really
tip its hand as to the specifics on that
whole front for quite a while into the
first season so I'm not gonna spoil that
here you know just in case anybody
watching doesn't already know going on
the run puts Rachel on the radar of dick
who's working as a police detective why
simultaneously trying and failing to
leave the life and work of Robyn behind
him this again does a pretty solid job
of handling what can and honestly has
been a bit of a sticking point about
this character it doesn't bug everybody
but it does kind of bug me and it's
often struck me as odd that in the
comics dick became a cop while still
doing the vigilante justice thing
because he's essentially just doing the
same job both day and night which it
doesn't give him a lot of nuance in
terms of you know just the potential
clash of his two worlds I mean you can
justify it as he does the work at night
in a way that the rules don't let him do
during the day but it makes him kind of
OneNote to me like there's nothing in
his life beyond fighting crime
so here the angle the show is working
from is that dick doesn't want to go out
as Robin anymore but is having a hard
time giving it up for reasons he's not
even entirely clear on himself so
becoming a cop is something that he does
in hope of basically getting able to do
the same work but the legitimate version
which might mean that he wouldn't still
have to go out
vigilante justice thing you know the
hope is that he won't still be on the
road to becoming another Batman which he
very much does not want except that need
whatever's driving him to do the
vigilante thing it doesn't go away and
this gives him some pretty legitimate
angst of his own the other two
characters on the show are notably less
angsty but for different reasons Cory
actually begins the show with pretty
complete amnesia she does not remember
who she is but she seems to both be in
the middle of some pretty wild events
and also has some devastating
superpowers mostly shooting flames from
her hands
amnesia is not exactly a bold new take
on well anything really however the
approach this character has to dealing
with it is basically what I for one have
a long wished more amnesia stories would
be she naturally wants to know who she
was and is working toward that goal but
she's not torn up and crying who am i
over it
I mean she's more annoyed than anything
else she's practical she seems to
instinctively get that boo-hooing over
the situation isn't gonna help and I
like that I like it a lot she enters
into the plot because she figures out
that at some point prior to her losing
her memory she was looking for Rachel
and she hopes that finding this young
woman that she might be able to tell
Cory who she actually is of course when
Cory finds Rachel it turns out that the
young girl doesn't have the first clue
who Corey is but they stick together
both in the hope that Cory can figure
this out you know as they go and also
because she recognizes that Rachel needs
help
and then there's gone who's the most
laid-back and least burdened of the
group he's he said that some moments of
angst but they're they're pretty light
given the fact that he was you know
brought back from the brink of death and
is now hiding out with the doomed
Rolle lest his powers get discovered
it's worth noting those who are fans of
this particular character he's he's a
bit nerfed in this show actually you
know pretty much all the superpower
characters are to some degree but his is
the most notable because instead of
being able to turn into any animal he
only is able to turn into a tiger now
that does appear to be kind of his like
it's it's his instinctive default so
there's still room for him to grow into
his powers and learn other stuff you
know down the line but that's all you're
getting in this one it's just the tiger
has anybody familiar with this team
should expect gah reforms the closest
bond to Rachel and thankfully it's
actually more mutual here than it's been
sometimes I've seen other iterations of
the depictions of Beast Boy where I kind
of felt like he was so persistent in the
face of Raven telling him to buzz off
that I just kind of wanted somebody to
mace him thankfully this doesn't fall
into that particular trap the show here
just lets gar be endearing in a way that
helps lighten the mood just enough
without feeling like there's nothing
more to him than just being the comic
relief the bonding growth and dynamic of
these four characters builds believably
over the course the first season and all
the actors are up to the task
I wouldn't say anybody really blew me
away on the acting front but nobody
drops the ball and given the way the
team needs to fit together that's more
than enough for me overall these four
are the heart of the show and also its
greatest strengths in addition it's
fairly well shot a little over dark at
times but I think we all expected that
from the first trailer it's not to the
degree of say some of the Marvel Netflix
shows where half the action scenes are
so dark that you cannot tell what in the
heck is even going on and even things
like say the violence level and the
occasional bit of cursing it feels
surprisingly organic to the moments when
they happen so these are the kind of
things these sorts of elements being
yell harsh or they usually they tend to
feel gratuitous but that thankfully was
not the case here when characters swear
it's because they're in a situation
where I think pretty much any of us
would have sworn to when somebody is
beaten bloody it's in an action scene
that had a narrative reason for
happening both when and how it did so
the blood it's not just for its own sake
the show as a whole displays an
impressive level of self-awareness when
it comes to the aspects that I was
expecting we're gonna derail the whole
thing those being the angst the darkness
the violence etc now it's not a
completely smooth ride I have mixed
feelings about the cult organization
that's hunting Rachel initially there
presented in a way that I pretty much
immediately fell in love with our first
real introduction to them is with this
family of four who is they are wholesome
to the point of feeling like they just
stepped out of a 1950 sitcom but they're
also a team of brutal assassins and I
love that contrast especially because
the nuclear family cheesiness comes
across as being absolutely sincere it
reminds me of the mayor from the third
season of Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
that is no bad thing unfortunately that
dichotomy diminishes as the show moves
along and we end up spending a fair
amount of time with the apparent head of
the cults who is a much more standard
monologuing villain type there's still a
little bit of that you know that
wholesomeness to him but I like the
family it lacked
the sincerity it feels well feels like
an act and is therefore infinitely less
engaging and entertaining and honestly I
feel like that juxtaposition between
tone and action was really the only
thing that was keeping this group from
just being completely generic so as the
presence of that dwindled I just didn't
really care much for or about this
organization they still function
he has plot drivers but they started out
as actually being more than that so it
was a bit frustrating for me as the
season went on I also want to touch on
some of the guest characters who appear
one of those is Jason Todd the new Robin
whose introduction ties pretty directly
with dicks own you know questioning of
his role as Robin and it works well with
that context behind it as dick has to
contend with the idea that somebody else
took up the mantle and doesn't see the
danger in it that he now does plus the
anxiety that comes from appearing that
it was incredibly easy for Batman to
replace him
that makes this a totally natural
inclusion and Jason is a little a little
bit of a prick as you would expect the
other three guest characters in their
episodes well a lot of them they feel
like backdoor pilots spin-offs you know
where we get the hero or the hero team
brought into the story and the show
really does feel like it's got one eye
on the audience going so what do you
think about this one getting their own
series yeah out of the three that are
handled this way one of them is about as
close to seamless as these sort of
things tend to be one is far less
seamless but still pretty enjoyable and
what it's just painful and annoying the
one that comes off the best I would say
is Donna Troy former sidekick to Wonder
Woman and she's brought in when dick
breaks off from the team for for a time
and basically needs somebody to confide
in about the fact that he's having
trouble
leaving Robin behind sometimes you're
confrontational hold on like right now
I'm not wow that was adult
they have good chemistry which helps and
also this whole question has been eating
at him the whole show already so when he
thinks Rachel's basically safe at least
for the time being it makes sense that
he turned to somebody like her for
guidance now a little less cleanly
integrated is the Doom Patrol they do
fit in do gars origin but there's an
entire episode that's basically devoted
to a little more than a Rachel getting
to meet each member of the team in turn
and then leave with gar in tow and so it
really does feel pretty removed from the
ongoing story so what helps is that the
Doom Patrol and the team members various
inherent weirdness is just fun to watch
I'm pretty compelling on its own I mean
when you have a group consisting of a
human mind stuck in a robot a former
movie star who's basically a big blob of
putty and a guy wrapped up in bandages
for reasons that are not immediately
apparent it's not too hard to get swept
up in the madness of it all
it may not push much of the overall
story of the season forward but it's fun
enough to work as a one-off sadly the
same can't be said for Hawk and Dove who
are not only poorly integrated into the
story they're boring annoying have
garishly bright costumes that feel very
out of place in this darker story and
world and eat up way more screen time
than anybody needed this is true of the
duo collectively but doubly true for
Hawk specifically this guy is just kind
of insufferable he's a big meathead with
less brains than muscle and he didn't
have the endearing streak that was
desperately needed to make me not hate
every single second he's on the screen I
know that he's supposed to be balanced
out by Dove but he needs to at least
work slightly as a character on his own
these two they get brought into the
story initially because
dick thinks it might be better to have
somebody else look after Rachel while
he's trying to sort out what's going on
which okay you know what as a concept
fair enough but even before we
understand why these two are here we are
treated to extended sequences of the
pair where I just kept muttering to
myself why am I having to watch these
two doofuses it also doesn't help that
later on they get a devoted origin
episode after being out of the story for
like five episodes and that origin for
them gets dropped immediately following
a cliffhanger ending from the previous
episode so the story that you know we're
invested in gets put on pause so we can
find out where these two morons came
from folks who watched stranger things
may actually get a little bit of deja vu
between this and the much-maligned
Episode seven of season two where the
main story was put on hold for a side
story about an absent character now I
actually didn't mind it in stranger
things because the cliffhanger in that
one was one that I both saw coming in
advance and had to me a pretty obvious
immediate resolution I wasn't you know I
wasn't going wow I didn't know that
would happen and I can't imagine what
comes next
you know so it kind of worked with
stranger things I felt I'm in the
minority on that whatever but here while
I did kind of see the setup for the
twist and the cliffhanger coming it is
still a twist cliffhanger that up ends
the dynamic of the show and puts the
characters in immediate moral danger
that does not have a clear way out this
is not the time to cut away to the
origin of two characters that I had
hoped I would never see again to be fair
the origin episode isn't actually all
that bad as a piece in and of itself
even though it completely wastes Marina
Sirtis
but again I don't even want an origin
for these two and this was absolutely
the wrong place to put it even if it
kind of works in a vacuum
I do want to reiterate that I was
actually pretty pleased with this first
season including the ending but I can't
go into more detail about that without
getting into some very explicit spoilers
so while I've done my best to go spoiler
of light up until now this is your
warning and your cue to bow out if you
don't want the last couple of episodes
of this first season of titans to be
dissected in detail before your eyes I
take you're not clicking off this video
as informed consent here we go the last
two episodes build really well helped
initially by the genuinely creepy vibe
given to the house the characters are in
there's a legitimate haunted house vibe
to the entire proceeding but it's not in
that jump-scare as soon as the jolt ends
the dread fades away kind of thing
no it's slower shots slightly off things
lingering images that disturb the
characters it creeps in without
resorting to trying to startle the
audience for a cheap jump then there's
the turn of Rachel's biological mother
Angela and the appearance of our final
villain I knew pretty much immediately
that the finale was liable to somehow
send her around Rachel's father the
demon Trigon because how else do you
climax a show with Raven moving most of
the plot now I had expected that it
would just end on the reveal of who
Trigon was or maybe the first hint of
his return to Earth be imminent so once
I realized that in fact no we're gonna
get him on screen like right now I
immediately got nervous because up to
this point the show had been extremely
economical with his special effects they
weren't used excessively often and they
you know they got the job done well and
because they were never too ambitious
for the budget but trigon a guy
generally depicted like this I really
dreaded a worst case Scorpion King style
faceplant and the finale is the worst
place of that kind of thing to happen so
I was surprised again when he ended up
being for now at least just a guy I
loved it he actually do a slight
disappointment on that on when it first
happened because despite my fear that it
was going to be a special-effects
faceplant I had kind of hoped to be
surprised by a bonkers visualization and
this made it look like well they're not
even trying
but then he started to speak and I got
on board pretty quickly
the casting works for me because I knew
this actor from the three or four years
that I watched the TV show Castle and on
that he had played a recurring
supporting role as a police detective
the guy's got a very likable presence
which is perfect for what the show is
doing the Trigon here because the show
isn't doing the standard generic final
evil villain spread darkness with his
arrival as some kind of big black
nebulous cloud of evil no it's a
metaphorical darkness
less tangible but no less destructive
Trigon here is a manipulator he's a
Corrupter and having an actor with an
inherent likability factor is perfect
for this this portrayal as well as the
villainous terms of Rachael's mother
also brought back that sinister
domesticity which was lost when the
villains were being led by that tool I
mentioned before now it's not quite on
the level of that assassin family but
Angela doesn't lose her softness when
her evil roots are revealed which is
another wonderful avoidance of a trope
that I loathe the secret villain who
wants their villainy is revealed to the
audience possibly to the heroes not
always behaves completely differently
from how they had up to that point it
happens so much it's
especially in superhero stories and I
get that when they're pretending to be
good that it's all an act but it's
usually such a drastic characterization
shift that the results feel less like a
twist in the same character and more
like the character was flat-out replaced
by somebody else that's not the case
with Rachel's mother she retains that
softness and affection even as she kills
a man he gets ready to help bring the
end of the world and Trigon himself is
not far off from being on the same line
he's playing the good cop he wants to
get you to trust him even as he gets you
to do something completely a guest
against your own best self-interest and
that's what I really love Trigon isn't
infecting or overriding people's free
wills with darkness he's putting them
into circumstances that will cause them
to voluntarily choose that darkness for
themselves it's done slightly heavy
handedly with using gars imminent death
to con Rachel and to bringing Trigon
into the world but after he's here he's
not cackling about being free at last he
embraces Angela and does in fact save
gar then there's what happens to dick so
the last episode also appears at first
to be disconnected from the one
immediately before what
unlike the stupid Hawk and Dove Origin
episode
it's a disconnect that fits because
given that the previous episode ended
would dick basically crossing into the
house where Trigon now has entered onto
our plane of existence having the next
episode opened with him happily married
to dawn aka dove with one child and
another on the way sets off about 50
alarm bells but this is an unreal
artificial and heavily manipulated
situation the show knows better than to
play that as a twist or a surprise it's
pretty obvious from the get-go and that
was very smart
so instead of trying to pull it do a rug
pool with it it used uses the episode to
give us a deep dive into how Trigon
operates how he corrupts and how he gets
people to choose the darkness because
that is technically what dick does he
makes that choice for himself but it's
also very clear that Trigon is
manipulating the situation to push dick
to that point the choice of darkness
versus light is done through the lens of
dick going back to Gotham to confront a
Batman who's completely lost his moral
tether and is on a rampage and every
time it looks like dick is gonna make
the choice that will take him further
away from the darkest possible outcome
the world wobbles a bit and then
something happens that changes the
situation and makes turning away all the
harder I love this for multiple reasons
firstly it's classic lawful evil Trigon
isn't lying when he tells Rachel that
dick chose the darkness but he omits
exactly how much nudging he had to do in
order to get dick to make that choice
and it it was a lot Batman putting
criminals in the hospital doesn't drive
our hero to the edge okay now he's gonna
kill the Joker practically in front of
dick not enough okay
now he's gonna kill every inmate guard
and the warden of Arkham Asylum still
not enough to get dick to go all the way
dark okay now he's gonna murder cops and
then quarry there it is that's enough
that when dick approaches a fallen
Batman reaching out for help he steps on
his neck
and kills him he was pushed enough that
he willingly submits to the darkness
but beyond the insight into trigons
style of manipulation I love how this
speaks to the themes of the difficulty
in
growing up and becoming an adult because
while Rachel Garr and even to a certain
extent Cory are confronting the issues
of teenagers dick is the adult in the
room but that doesn't make his life any
less difficult because one of the things
that's hard about adult life is the fact
that doing the right thing is not a
choice that you make once it's a choice
that you have to keep making over and
over again as situations get worse and
the choice gets harder you have to keep
saying no to the nihilistic instinct to
go to hell with all of it again and
again and again and even with
innumerable times of making the right
choice
it only takes one self-destructive oh
[ __ ] it moment to do an incredible
amount of possibly irreparable damage
this is a stellar closer to the first
season I love this finale has a
narrative in and of itself I love it as
an Elseworlds exploration of Robin and
to some extent Batman I love what it
reveals about our lead villain and his
MO and I absolutely adore how it feeds
into the growing of themes of the show
and these characters this finale shows
that Titans wasn't just winging it it
ties the themes together and takes them
to the next level in a way that only
happens when you know what you're doing
and you've got a plan I will say that I
can't help but be nervous about how
things pick up in the next season
because these kinds of season-ending
plot twists they have a tendency to get
cleared up within the first one or two
episodes before just moving on to
something else and that kind of thing it
undermines the weight of what happened
but then again this show has already
surprised me on more than one occasion
with how its sidestepped the landmines
that I was expecting it to step on if
only because I've seen so many other
shows do it before so despite some
hiccups along the way with a filler
villain in the middle and the
shoehorning in of some of the guest
characters this was a shockingly solid
piece of work well I can't say that that
first trailer was misrepresenting the
final product it absolutely sold it
short when it comes to the depth and
care with which it plays with darker
plot and character terms it made it look
like it was just doing it because it was
edgy but it's there for a reason
and having now seen the reason yeah I
gotta say I respect this which
definitely off that first trailer I was
not expecting to so that's gonna wrap up
this one folks my thoughts on season 1
of titans have you seen it
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop them on down in the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff to do down then there as well
all the buttons links patreon P o box
check them out and or don't that's okay
too because at the end of the day you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]